joining me now is stephen miller america
first legal founder and former trump
senior adviser at the white house and
also with me as indiana congressman jim
banks republican study committee steve
um
it is this just giving the democrats
cover
to stick it to americans and continue
this war on private vehicle ownership
and use in the united states
well it is very convenient they shut
down america's pipelines they canceled
leases for oil and natural gas drilling
they put enormous new restrictions on
the ability to explore and expand energy
domestically and now they're saying oh
well you're really paying more for
energy because of vladimir putin so it
really has nothing to do with any of the
policy choices that we've made here in
america the truth is there's one problem
america should truly never have and that
is paying high prices at the pump or
paying high prices to heat or cool your
home because we are one of the most
energy rich nations on planet earth we
had energy independence under donald
trump and they made a decision a
voluntary decision to end our energy
independence congressman banks think of
where would be today vis-a-vis russia
and the leverage they would have over us
or not if we had just left trump's
policies in place
this is just yet another example of the
situation around us crumbling because
biden stayed on the fanaticism and away
from common sense
yeah lori across the board whether you
whether you're talking about going
overnight from being an energy
independent nation to one that's reliant
on oil coming from foreign countries
especially from our adversaries like
russia whether you're talking about the
border crisis or crime rates around this
country on almost every crisis and issue
facing america today there is a direct
line between decisions that joe biden
and this administration made in the very
first days on when they came into office
and the crisis that we're facing in this
country today and and the very fact that
across the board on average americans
are spending a buck and a quarter more
per gallon for gasoline at the pumps
that that's directly related as stephen
said to stopping
drilling on on federal lands and in
ending construction of the keystone
pipeline that's why you're spending more
at the pump it's not because of vladimir
putin and stephen the numbers for biden
and the new gallup poll on russia
are abysmal we keep asking how low can
he go and polls the question is is there
even a floor for biden's support i'm not
sure there is
but it keeps edging lower and lower and
lower and do you think there's
a hunger for more military involvement
in
in this situation ever precarious as it
is in ukraine
no there most assuredly is not and i
will say if you study the history of
world war one
what you know is that complex networks
of alliances combined with foolish hasty
or rash thinking can potentially lead to
enormous and deadly conflict and so we
have to tread with extreme care and
caution here we have to keep in mind
part of the reason why people are so
upset at joe biden is while they're
seeing him stumbling and bumbling around
europe talking about ukrainian
sovereignty they're also keenly aware of
the fact that joe biden has actually
launched a full-scale assault on
american sovereignty and has erased our
own southern border so while we're
paying more for energy prices because of
his failed europe policy
we are paying in american lives for his
failed border policy and there was a
interesting comment made by the pentagon
spokesman
about this burgeoning bromance between
president xi and putin congressman i
want to play it for you
we certainly have been watching the at
least public burgeoning relationship
here between russia and china we would
say that
their
tacit support if you will for russia is
deeply alarming um and frankly
even more destabilizing uh to the
security situation uh in europe
yeah more destabilizing i believe he
said than even you know what russia is
doing in ukraine congressman who's
responsible for driving putin into xi's
harms are we still saying arms are you
still saying it's donald trump's fault
with that without a doubt it's the we
have the weakest president perhaps ever
in the white house on a daily basis
projects a weakness and appeasement to
our adversaries for four years the world
was far more safe on donald trump's
watch than any single day that joe biden
has been in office i mean that is a fact
everything every everything that we see
from from russian aggression to china
continuing to move toward their ultimate
goals iran on the rise again acting out
and and uh
and and and and firing uh uh missiles
and rockets at our greatest uh our
greatest ally in israel across the board
the world is far more safe for four
years under trump than it's ever been
with joe biden in the white house since
that weakness that putin is seeing
that's why he's that's why he's acting
out at this moment i'm telling you
chairman xi and the chinese communist
party the pla are watching the biden
weakness as well um which is going to
have even more disastrous consequences
down the road steve why do the elites
think that americans care more about
defending ukraine's border than our
southern border
i never did figure that out
i think that for some of them there's
obviously a lot of financial interest
involved and we've seen that with
president biden's family i think in
other cases i think there's always been
amongst both neocons and democrats
a segment who are excited by the
prospect of foreign adventure overseas
while being completely emotionally
disconnected from and having no in fact
emotional attachment to their own
citizens their own country their own
borders and this administration typifies
that personifies it as no administration
ever has before they truly do not care
about the fact that you have chinese
fentanyl pouring through mexico into our
communities murdering our citizens you
have criminal illegal aliens being freed
preying on innocence and they don't even
care no compassion for the american
lives being lost gentlemen thank you
both for being here tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else